i can't be a
wizard from casual words to epic final
phrases
these harry potter characters had
totally surprising arrays of opening and
closing lines
which character does a total 180 an
attitude from their first line to their
last line
how about whose lines are about the boy
who lived let's have a look
i'm ron by the way from weasley i'm
harry harry potter
when we meet the boy who lived he's
obedient as can be yes on petunia
we get to watch his journey from young
orphan boy to leader in the wizarding
world and father to his son
his last line ready feels like a very
appropriate end
passing his legacy on to the next
generation ron's first line is
appropriately addressed to harry excuse
me
do you mind everywhere else is full here
we get to see the beginning of their
lifelong friendship
his final line at the end of the deathly
hallows part 2 is the perfect
demonstration of just how far the
friends have come together most powerful
wand in the world
with that would be invincible ron
suggesting that having the elder wand
would make the trio invincible depicts
just how strong their relationship is
as well as his sense of ambition off the
bat of the first film we see hermione as
a sweet helpful
young witch looking out for others has
anyone seen a toad
by the end of the movies her final line
is very simple
we while the line is short it
demonstrates
how she's grown to be a confident and
strong witch and that she has no problem
calling ron out
ginny's very first and last lines are
both to do with harry potter himself
good luck first we see the shy young
girl amazed by the boy who lived
by the time we get to see her in the
final film she's a woman who's really
come into her own and found the love of
her life
even though she thought he was gone in
this instance
albus dumbledore's first line is pretty
functional
but it also gives us a hint as to how
well knowing he could be
i should have known that you would be
here
professor mcgonagall by the final film
after dumbledore has passed on
we get a line that really captures how
integral his wisdom has been
guiding harry over the years why should
that mean
that it's not real then we have his
brother we hear about for years but
first meet near the end of the film saga
bloody fools what were you thinking
coming here
both his first and last lines give us a
lot of information about the past
his initial scolding and then with his
last words
he gave her everything
good time we were able to understand why
he and albus had such a strained
relationship
while both hagrid's first and final
lines are simple we get to see
how significant his relationships with
many important wizards are
professor dumbledore sir professor
mcgonagall
there is definitely a connection between
these two since the first is the
beginning of hagrid addressing helping
harry potter
and in the end even though he thinks
harry has died
all he can bring himself to say is harry
hurry
may be one word but it's packed with
emotion
when it comes to sirius black his lines
do a total 180.
no only one would die tonight we see him
go from battling against harry to
supporting the boy
even from the land of the dead
these lines really exhibit the course
and strength of their relationship over
the years
neville's growth over the series of the
films is pretty monumental
his first line is the perfect depiction
of the bumbling awkward boy we meet
his transformation to true leader with a
heart of gold is obvious with one of the
most powerful lines in the final film
for all of us this
pretty much sums up how great a friend
and wizard neville grows up to be
both luna's first and final words are
addressed to harry
you're not going mad is a perfect intro
for her character
an odd girl who is much wiser than she
seems
in her final line we get to see how
close she and harry have become
it's very impressive isn't it as well as
the fact that luna is keenly observant
and
often providing answers for harry when
he needed the most
professor mcgonagall is one of the first
hogwarts teachers we meet
and she definitely sets the impression
of a wise woman in charge
good evening professor dumbledore her
final line of the movies
is quite different and absolutely one of
the most epic that she has
i've always wanted to use that spell we
get to see a different side of her
personality which only makes us love her
more
funnily enough both draco's first and
final lines are addressed to harry
potter
it's true then what they're saying on
the train while draco was never harry's
best friend he wasn't
all bad both his lines are kind of
confrontational but his last line
somewhat inadvertently helps harry
understand me
know what i mean so we get to see how
draco goes from harry potter hater
to a wizard who helps harry even if it's
not entirely on purpose
voldemort's first haunting line depicts
pretty much what we expect
an obsession with destroying the boy who
lived
the fact that the line is done as a
voice over only adds to the fact that
voldemort's presence is powerful and
vast
by the time his last line comes around
he's still the evil villain we've known
him to be all along as his last words
are as vicious and dark as he is
the weasley twins are pretty much the
same from the beginning to the end
he's not fred i am honestly woman you
call yourself
our mother what comes through most
powerfully is their relationship with
each other
whether they're being foolish tricksters
playing a prank or two brothers taking
on every tragedy life throws at them by
each other's side
yeah me too
yet another character with both first
and last lines about the boy who lived
both her opening and final words really
demonstrate her obsession with ending
his life
itsy bitsy baby
the fact that in both lines she refers
to him as either a baby or boy
shows just how much she thought of him
as a child boy
is he dead making her vilex against him
that much worse
lupine's first line shows us just how
helpful he is
reaching out to harry when he's in need
here eat this
it'll help it's all right it's chocolate
unfortunately his final words in the
film come when he's no longer alive
but it speaks to his character and the
legacy that he leaves behind
one day he'll understand while cedric
diggory's first line doesn't leave too
much of an impression
his joyful smile and charm definitely do
this dropping young lad must be cedric
am i right sir
in the end his final words against
voldemort really sum up his bravery
who are you what do you want making this
a perfect final line for his character
arthur and molly weasley two of the
strongest
funniest most supportive people we got
to know in the wizarding world
arthur's first and final lines are
addressing groups
first his family then the order of
phoenix group
two three we see him as a leader in team
player from beginning to end
looking back to the philosopher's stone
we meet molly with her sassy remark
packed with muggles of course come on
back from nine and three quarters this
way
when we get to our final words in the
deathly hallows part two
we get a very different version of sass
and we
are here for it not my daughter humor
oh the malfoys both lucius and narcissa
are nasty characters but as indicated by
both their first and last lines in the
films their son draco is their primary
focus
lucius first speaks in the second film
play nicely his final words are a public
plea to draco to stand on their side
with the dark lord
we don't hear narcissist speak until the
half blood prince and when she does
it's in preparation to speak to snape
about protecting draco
i i know i want to be here her final
words very similar to her husband
are a plea for draco to stand with them
from the first moment we meet him
dobby's kindness shines through
harry potter we see an elf who's been
mistreated but
finally overcomes and becomes a free elf
though
always faithful to those he loves his
final line before he passes
is devastating but also a perfect
example of just how loyal he is
to be with his friend harry potter
we only get to see nymphadora tonks for
two of the films
her first line is pretty indicative of
her spunk and humor
i clean these knuckles thanks for god's
sake
her life is taken too soon but her final
word is a simple one
i won't be standing here without while
she may not have appeared in the films
for very long
she definitely still made a strong
impact filch
one of the grumpiest squibs there ever
was his main role in the films is in
relation to the students of hogwarts and
his first line coming through the crowd
is pretty spot on for this what's going
on out
come on my way my way throughout the
movies he continues to blubber
on until his very last line when he yet
again
mumbles to a group of students
just before we meet professor slughorn
we meet this armchair
a surprising intro but it says a lot
about his skills as a wizard
his final line to harry is loaded
telling us a lot about both his own past
and the reality of how much of a monster
the dark lord had been for so many years
no idea what he was like even then
her shrill and condescending tone comes
straight through in her first line
i'm sure i must have misunderstood you
we see umbridge become more and more
villainous over the course of the films
her final suspicious words come from
inside the ministry of magic
shortly after which she's duped and
stupefied
what on earth are you doing albert
spunky sheamus comes out of the gates
and philosophers stone with a pretty
straightforward explanation of who he is
[Music]
in the end he puts his pyrotechnic
skills to good use and we see the
glimmer in his eyes that makes him a
great wizard
i can bring it down dean thomas's first
word is
in unison with his classmates
demonstrating his role as a member of
the gryffindor team
his final words are simple but they just
reinforce his commitment to his fellow
classmates and friends
where is it some of these lines are so
surprising
especially since many characters appear
again afterwards and don't actually end
up speaking
many of their journeys really come
through perfectly with their initial and
final dialogue which first and last
lines were your favorite